movies have become so reliant on digital
effects that their original footage is
often completely unrecognizable from
what you see on screen here's what these
movies really look like before the
special effects were added leading
manlyonato DiCaprio and director
Alejandro g inyari 2 weren't the only
ones to gain recognition for their work
on 2015's the Revenant from riding a
horse off a cliff to an epic bear attack
ilm the digital team behind the film
special effects had their work cut out
for them the true hero of this film
though was Glenn Ennis the six foot four
stuntman who played the iconic bear was
hard on the body so you know on your
hands and feet picking someone up
throwing them around Ennis also admitted
that DiCaprio was a pretty intense
co-star the a-listers agony was so
believable that Ennis thought he was
actually hurting him
despite failing to recoup its 110
million dollar budget nobody could deny
that 2016's passengers looked great
director Morton tildum wanted to keep
the visual effects as subtle as possible
affects company MPC was behind many of
the film's iconic shots including a
beautiful zero gravity water sequence
however those special effects may be
accessible they certainly aren't cheap
NPC's visual effects supervisor Pete
Dion told Art of VFX Morton's aesthetic
is definitely biased towards invisible
effects and where they couldn't be
invisible by nature to keep them
restrained and to never distract from
the drama Warner Brothers maxed out
their 250 million dollar budget for
Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice and
although the film made tons of money
critics still weren't impressed director
Zack Snyder received a lot of flack but
he claimed that he and his effects team
actually went out of their way to pay
homage to the source material take
Superman's cape for instance VFX
supervisor Brian hirota told Art of VFX
it had to act and feel natural but on
the other hand behaving an art-directed
way and create appealing shapes that
remind the viewer of the original Comics
that may sound like a nice detail but
it's a safe bet that everyone was too
busy trying to spot actor Henry cavill's
CGI Ray's mustache in Justice League to
go back and notice the Hunger Games
franchise split its final book into two
movies and most fans agree that the
second was far more exciting than the
first fee effects supervisor Charles
Gibson described Mockingjay Part 2 as a
war film with massive set pieces saying
we had to enhance battle action and
create believable environments that
would hold up for extended coverage
working closely with production designer
Phil Messina Gibson agreed on a mix of
shooting on location and building
digital sets saying that Messina's input
on the project and its design approach
were invaluable South Korean director
bong Joon ho turned countless Netflix
users vegan in 2017 with obja the
touching story of a girl and a Super Pig
the effects supervisor a Ricky on the
boar explained that the success of the
film hinges on whether the audience
believed that sculpture a genetically
engineered Pig was real as he explained
to no film school the only way that
people are really going to believe major
and oakja and their little pet
friendship is if we have a lot of
contact and if that contact is truly
believable in order to achieve this
physical contact the VFX team created a
range of foam props for young star on
sohyun to interact with including a full
body suit for the most intimate
interactions fortunately the effort paid
off as Oak just struck a chord with both
viewers and critics alike the sequel to
Ridley Scott's Seminole sci-fi classic
Blade Runner was a long time coming and
the VFX team felt the weight of the 80s
cult classic on their shoulders overall
visual effects supervisor John Nelson
told Art to VFX any fan of science
fiction or Cinema has a great deal of
reverence for the original Blade Runner
myself included Blade Runner 2049
cityscapes in particular were a huge job
and multiple VFX companies were hired to
craft this world in miniature while the
film fell below box office expectations
it did at least manage to capture the
neon Noir feeling that resonated with
fans of the original so strongly before
Blade Runner 2049 the Neville nerve
directed a Sci-Fi outing that was a
little more grounded in reality 2016's
arrival follows a linguist and a
physicist as they attempt to communicate
with an alien species the VFX style was
the polar opposite of the Blade Runner
sequel seeming drab and washed out in
comparison VFX supervisor and regular
collaborator Lewis Morin told VFX blog
vionov wanted nothing to do with any
kind of sci-fi movie that we've been
seeing recently from Hollywood he just
wanted this movie to feel so real and so
boring in so many ways like ordinary
looking Lewiston talked about a cold
cloudy day in Montreal where villanov
explained that this was what he wanted a
rival to look like considering how gray
and rubbed the film looked it's safe to
say he nailed it Alex Garland in the
Sci-Fi drama ex machina beat out many
big budget films to win the best
achievement in visual effects Oscar in
2016. according to VFX supervisor Andrew
Whitehurst the shoot was so well known
organized and efficient that they had
extra cash to spend on making Ava the AI
look amazing he explained that the
initial budget would have only allowed
them to animate Ava's torso and Limbs
and that the extra money let them
animate her head and neck as well
Garland also wanted to make sure Ava had
romantic appeal costume designer Sami
Sheldon differ explains that her suit
which left little to the imagination was
a massive group effort Zack Snyder's 300
made heavy use of CGI and the technology
used to create it had Advanced immensely
by the time its sequel Rise of an Empire
came around which of course meant
squeezing every ounce of that Tech into
the movie director no Muro told Forbes
it's amazing how the tools available
eight years later continue to develop a
major difference is CGI and the ability
to create things in posts that are
convincing and complex and
three-dimensional the idea of creating a
water movie without a drop of water on
the set is remarkable the filmmaker also
revealed that they relied on some of the
same techniques used in the
oscar-winning CGI Blockbuster gravity
Neil blomkamp's follow up to is
acclaimed debut District 9 didn't
exactly go as planned despite the star
power of Matt Damon the Blockbuster
sci-fi film cost a whopping 115 million
dollars to make but only returned 93
million dollars at the domestic box
office but while bloemcamp took full
responsibility for the film's failings
the South African director didn't have
any complaints about the special effects
team which had to put together over
three times as many VFX shots as they
had for district 9. when Steven
Spielberg decided to adapt Michael
crichton's novel Jurassic Park CGI as we
know it today didn't really exist
Spielberg brought on industrial Light
and magic and tasked them with creating
living breathing dinosaurs using
computer generated graphics and their
efforts proved revolutionary of course
it wasn't just CGI that brought the
inhabitants of Jurassic Park to life
there were a number of practical effects
used too and ilm mixed it up in the same
way for Jurassic world the fourth film
in the franchise used detailed white
casts of dinosaur heads that would later
be layered with with CGI for close-up
shots and they used actors in motion
capture suits to make sure their
movement seemed real VFX supervisor Tim
Alexander told below the line it gave us
a new natural look for the animation we
ended up casting a person to give us a
consistency in the performance there
were individual people being that Raptor
we had suits that they would put on with
a tail when George Miller returned to
the world of Mad Max with his critically
acclaimed Fury Road in 2015. audiences
were blown away by the sequels frenetic
pace and visceral action much of which
was achieved through the hard work of
inventive mechanics who built the
vehicles used in the movie from scratch
the chase scenes were all shot for real
but the final product wouldn't have
looked anywhere near as eye-popping if
it weren't for the VFX team led by
supervisor Andrew Jackson hundreds of
CGI artists enhanced over 2 000 shots in
Fury Road from adding characters to
creating an epic toxic storm
when Earth's Mightiest Heroes teamed up
on the big screen in 2012 the stakes
were high for Marvel Studios and their
team of visual effects artists Jeff
White the film's VFX supervisor told MTV
with Adventures there were so many
things to get right we created a lot of
New York City for the film and needed to
build flying shots of Iron Man all from
photography we had to build a new Iron
Man suit the Mark VII and Stark Tower we
had to build the alien race when you add
all of those things up there were quite
a few challenges there green screens
were used during most of the film's
action sequences so the cast's been a
good chunk of time reacting to Invisible
threats and taking cover from fake
explosions the biggest hurdle they faced
was inserting the Hulk into group
situations white explained we wanted it
to feel very natural when he's sitting
in that Circle of Avengers we spent a
lot of time working on his skin and his
hair and his teeth just to make sure all
of that was believable
to create the illusion of flight Richard
Donner's Superman employed wire rigs to
hang leading man Christopher Reeve in
front of different projected backgrounds
the film is a classic and the effects
look great in the 70s but watching it
today it feels as though you're flying
with Superman as opposed to him flying
past you something Man of Steel director
Zack Snyder wanted to avoid when he set
out to make Superman soar Snyder decided
to use a handheld approach to filming
Clark's flying scenes which meant adding
in most of the effects in post wire Rigs
and gimbals were used to suspend Henry
Cavill in front of green screens and the
CGI team did the rest
when the first Iron Man movie dropped in
2008 director John Favreau wasn't known
for CGI heavy features but advances in
technology had convinced him to change
his stance I've always steered away from
using visual effects whenever possible
that being said in the last few years
there have been a lot of wonderful
visual effects movies where I it it's
beginning to become seamless even to me
favro returned for the sequel but Shane
black took the reins for Iron Man 3
which contained some of the most
challenging visual effects yet Marvel
Studios head honcho Kevin feige
explained we wanted the ability to be
able to suit up anywhere anyhow without
a giant Gantry the answer was having
Tony Stark design Outlets he injects
just below the skin not unlike the
comics allowing him to call the Iron Man
suit from anywhere to pull off the
effect each individual piece had to be
digitally added to Robert Downey Jr's
body after the fact
years of gymnastics training really paid
off for Tom Holland on the set of
Spider-Man homecoming the characters
eagerly anticipated introduction to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe even with the
advances in CGI in recent years it helps
to have an actor who feels comfortable
jumping around in tights and doesn't
mind hanging around on wires all day
long this was the case with the film's
Washington Monument scene but while that
was indeed Holland under the Spidey mask
the monument itself was a fake erected
on the studio Sound Stage we couldn't
film at the real washing Monument but we
built very impressive very large chunks
of the monument for filming Holland got
up the structure with the aid of a wire
rig though even with his background it
was far from a walk in the park we did
two weeks and every single shot was
upside down and my head just took a
pounding man from all the Bloods that
was rushing to it the CGI John Favreau
used for Iron Man was nothing compared
to what he did for his 2016 live action
adaptation of the Jungle Book to create
an entire jungle around a human actor
they needed to pull out all the stops
the lighting was particularly difficult
the director explained it's very hard to
fake light and Shadow so everything
became about using panels of LEDs to
project light so if we had the kid
bowing before the elephants you have
panels where we actually would
pre-animate the elephants and they would
cast the Shadows on the kid in the exact
right way this meant that 12 year old
star Neil seti had to imagine the
animals he was interacting with though
Favre was on hand to make the experience
as real as possible for the young actor
via puppets and actors in blue suits
Paul verhoven's RoboCop got the most out
of the special effects available in the
80s using a combination of stop-motion
and prosthetic builds to create a movie
that was disturbingly realistic at times
in a 2014 reboot Murphy gets his
injuries in an explosion that was
created digitally but the suit he dons
afterward was actually real and there
was a philosophy from the start that
we're going to have a head to toe suit
the challenge was building a suit that
was mobile and easy for the digital
Department to add on to
Ridley Scott is no stranger to special
effects but creating the red planet on
screen for the Martian may have been his
biggest challenge as a director while
some practical effects were used a huge
amount of digital work was required to
give the Martian Scott's desired look
VFX supervisor Anders lenglands told
Gizmodo Ridley Scott is famous for doing
his little sketches which are sort of
really cool Ridley grams we'd ask what
do you want the background mountains to
look like in this shot and he'd sketch
out a little diagram of what they wanted
so you just literally match that and
he'd be happy a lot of time was spent
finding the right cue for the skies and
arid Landscapes of Mars though in the
end it was a simple thing that caused
the VFX team the most problems the
helmet visors but of course glass visors
would reflect the crew and the lights
and the soundstage so all the helmet
visors you see in the film are actually
added in digitally David Ayers anti-hero
Ensemble Suicide Squad definitely had
its flaws but few of those were the
fault of the mini visual effects houses
18 companies in total that work
tirelessly on it imageworks were the
ones who handled the squad's final
battle with enchantress and the movie's
villain proved to be a huge challenge
according to VFX supervisor Mark
breakspeare he told Art of VFX
enchantress was a unique challenge as
the actress had been shot without a
costume as we had to add it in later to
allow it to behave in a way that normal
cloth or materials couldn't break spear
later told awn that of the 300 shots
they enhanced for the film's third act
dealing with the enchantress's tattoos
proved the most difficult that was
amazingly tricky to make sure it looked
like skin but also had the translucency
that we needed to see the subsurface
tattoos
Watching Martin scorsese's Ode to excess
The Wolf of Wall Street the only scenes
that stick out as being possibly
computer generated are the wondering
which Jordan Belford's yacht sinks and
the one when a lion wanders freely
through his office but a visual effects
real released by brainstorm digital
revealed that some of the most basic
shots in the movie were rendered with
CGI from Sun loungers to tennis courts
brainstorm made plenty of subtle touches
to bring the film in line with the
director's Vision VFX producer Mark
Russell told Digital Arts working with
Martin Scorsese everything is about
propelling a story forward and
contributing to the film I feel that
with his movies there is a kind of
stylized realism to them that we have to
integrate with
the amount of Destruction on show in
this Dwayne johnson-led Blockbuster
definitely doesn't come cheap but San
Andreas actually cost a lot less to make
than many of the big natural disaster
flicks that came before it according to
variety the production budget was only
114 million dollars roughly half the
amount needed to bring Roland emmerich's
2012 to the big screen the film's visual
effects supervisor Colin Strauss was
able to keep costs down by employing
practical solutions to problems that
most visual effects companies would
solve with only computers today as he
explained it you can make a 100 million
dollar movie look like a 200 million
dollar movie you can make movies way
smarter CG for the sake of CG is always
a mistake effects Studio WETA digital
changed the game when they helped reboot
Planet of the Apes with a new Trilogy of
prequels beginning with 2011's Rise of
the Planet of the Apes producer Dylan
Clark had a special amount of praise for
Andy Circus the industry's top
performance capture artist shown as
protagonist Caesar redefining screen
acting in the digital age
Andy Circus is unlike any other actor he
can inhabit characters that don't speak
and emote in ways that you don't really
see often Fox campaigned for circus to
get an Oscar nomination but the call
from the academy never came much to the
actor's frustration after the release of
2017's War of the Planet of the Apes
circus told independent the awarding
bodies should not discriminate about
this being different the visual effects
render the character just like putting
on makeup except here it happens after
the fact it's digital makeup if you will
bringing JK Rowling's Wizarding World to
life was only ever going to be possible
with the help of CGI and the films made
increasingly good use of visual effects
with each installment while early CGI
hasn't aged well the quality of digital
imagery from Goblet of Fire onward still
holds up the VFX team had to up their
game for the fourth film in the series
as it marked the return of Lord
Voldemort Paul Franklin the VFX
supervisor for Order of the Phoenix and
Half-Blood Prince revealed that creating
Voldemort's nose was a mammoth task
Franklin told radio times there's this
idea that we put the shots through the
computer and it just vanished off his
face his nose had to be painstakingly
edited out frame by frame over the whole
film and then the snake slits had to be
added and tracked very carefully using
dots put on his face for reference
that's a lot of work for a couple no
slits but Voldemort just wouldn't have
been the same without them
nothing's too good for James Potter
filming this tale of a boy stranded at
Sea with a Bengal tiger came with a
number of obstacles but the biggest one
wasn't the tiger it was the water
director Ang Lee explained I knew that
to make it work with 3D water had to
become a character itself I've never
seen realistic water scenes in movies
because water hits one side of a tank
wall and bounces back like it would in a
bathtub but we needed to make it work
that's not to say the tiger was easy to
create either scenes in which Pi
interacts with the deadly animal were
done using a crude puppet the rest of it
had to come from CGI
Tim Burton was creating stunning visual
effects long before relying heavily on
CGI using a combination of practical
techniques to bring his vision to the
screen the former Disney artist used
stop-motion animation Miniatures and
puppetry to great effect in his earlier
works though in the opportunity to
direct his own version of Alice in
Wonderland came along he soon realized
that he couldn't do it without leaning
heavily on digital Wizardry this means
that all the stars of the movie had to
do the bulk of their acting in front of
green screens according to visual
effects supervisor Ken Ralston it was a
challenge for the whole team the green
screen color after long periods of time
seems to create a certain aggravation
and irritation after staring at it for a
long period it is effective for
compositing but visually and
psychologically exhausting to be
surrounded by it for extended periods of
time
when Disney first announced their
intention to remake a number of their
beloved animated Classics and
live-action format the title that raised
the most eyebrows was Beauty and the
Beast a film in which the majority of
the supporting characters are animated
household objects was always going to
rely on CGI though director Bill Condon
has never liked digital effects and
actively avoided using them wherever
possible he told Indie wire it was
important to make everything that could
be real real I'm not a big fan of CG
movies the idea is to feel grounded in a
world and not be distracted by things
that felt like additions unfortunately
for the actor portraying the Beast Dan
Stevens it was motion capture all the
way plus some stilts to get him to the
right height it wasn't easy on stilts
Steven spoke to both Andy Circus and
Mark Ruffalo about their experiences and
motion capture roles and their feedback
left him sweating he added I think I was
mildly terrified but that's really
generally what drives a lot of my
decisions these days is calibrating the
right amount of Terror nothing like a
Disney movie to get that fear meter up
right
Christopher Nolan is notorious for using
real life effects as much as possible
and most of the big effects in the Dark
Knight were done on camera the only
visual effect involved in that scene was
to remove the ram that they had built
inside the truck but the Dark Knight
still offered some unique CG challenges
especially since it was the first film
to shoot scenes with IMAX cameras as
opposed to using 35 millimeter and
converting in post visual effects
supervisor Nick Davis spoke to Studio
daily about his experience on the Batman
flick saying it was important for the
visual effects to look as though they
were shot on set Nolan didn't want the
film to take on a gimmicky visual
effects look taking this route meant
that Nolan's first sequel to 2005's
Batman Begins was a difficult movie to
finish as the visual effects had to be
rendered in a higher resolution than
ever before when it came to creating the
look for Harvey two-faced Dent Nolan
wanted to remove layers not add them the
VFX team had to digitally remove the
skin two faces exposed eyeball had to be
painstakingly animated by hand as were
the subtle changes in muscle tension the
biggest challenge Alfonso coron faced
making his space epic gravity was
achieving a realistic lack of gravity on
screen pulling it off involved an
intricate mixture of practical and
digital effects now there are flares and
there are mistakes as it were but no
mistakes it's all created
the director talked to space about the
challenges and getting the effects to
look realistic saying it took a lot of
education for the animators to fully
grasp that the usual laws of cause and
effect don't apply in outer space there
is no up there is no down co-stars
Sandra Bullock and George Clooney were
advised of their movements by real
astronauts before being hooked up to a
series of rigs created by Academy
award-winning visual effects artist Neil
corbold it turns out that Bullock not
only had to put up with being suspended
from wires most of the day there were
electric shocks to contend with too
corbold explained there was a charge in
there like the static you feel
underneath an electricity substation if
you walked out then touched someone
you'd get this massive shock it may not
have been easy work for the actors but
it worked out pretty well for corbold
who won his second Oscar for Gravity
arguably one of the most influential
films of all time the Matrix truly
changed the landscape of action movies
with its memorable fight sequences
becoming a benchmark for stunt
coordinators and VFX artists alike the
term bullet time was coined for the Epic
slow motion shots that the movie
employed on the regular which were
created by visual effects Guru John Gada
geda told the New York Times the
directors wanted to emulate the
stylization found in Japanese animation
when we created weather fire and smoke
we wanted it to move not realistically
but impressionistically raw footage
released as an extra on the DVD showed
how bullet time was achieved using an
intricate setup of perfectly positioned
cameras and masses of green screen
whenever Peter Jackson's The Lord of the
Rings trilogy comes up the first thing
most people mention is Andy circus's
brilliant motion capture performance
though creating Gollum was just one of
many challenges what a face during the
movies practical Solutions like
miniature models and forced perspective
were used in places but the bulk of the
visual effects were achieved digitally
even the interior of Bilbo baggins's
Hobbit Hole was computer generated for
some shots speaking to awn visual
effects supervisor Jim rigel revealed
that Return of the King was his favorite
of the three movies because of the
Monumental amount of work he and his
team put into the picture he explained
Return of the King has more shots than
one and two combined it's like 1 450. it
was mind-boggling to figure out
logistically how to do them all it's
something you never think you could have
done and you did it like climbing Mount
Everest Bill nye's character Davey Jones
made his first appearance in 2006 as
Dead Man's Chest although he may not
have recognized the actor under all
those digital tentacles I was once
required to be a squid man in a movie I
was an octopus guy and I was perfectly
happy watching that because what are you
going to say my you don't like my squid
well then you know live with it visual
effects supervisor John Knoll was able
to develop a method that allowed naive
to be on set with his fellow actors
instead of filming separately in front
of a green screen which in turn allowed
him to interact more believably and
deliver a far more genuine performance
Knoll described the process to ew saying
on a sound stage with 25 technicians
staring at Bill and nobody to play off
of that quirkiness would have all gotten
ironed out somebody would say that
gesture is too off or too odd it could
have become a real sort of committee
effort my squid was world class my my
squid was an award-winning squid because
the hundred men and women who created my
squid the post-credits scene in Pirates
of the Caribbean Dead Men tell no Tales
opened the door for the return of
Supernatural Sea Lord Davy Jones
although naive had no part in it in fact
he had no idea his award-winning squid
was even in the movie until a taxi
driver told him about it the season
finales on Game of Thrones always have a
cinematic quality thanks in part to the
digital Wizardry of pixel Mondo green
screen use has kept to a minimum where
possible but bringing the creatures of
George R.R Martin's world into the mix
requires some top-notch CGI pixel
Mondo's VFX supervisor Sven Martin told
the Washington Post that one of their
biggest achievements has been making
Daenerys dragons blend seamlessly with
the world around them but all that magic
doesn't happen until the dragon scenes
have been shot so how does Emilia Clarke
connect with her fire-breathing babies
green puppets the actress told
Huffington Post they have these Amazing
Life scale models that we use for camera
rehearsals for the sake of the CGI
people and I got very attached to them
fundamentally they're dolls I suppose
but it was nice to have something
physical that I could really picture in
my mind
foreign